if a guy tells me that he's would date a
single mother i'm like
like i feel like your your vetting
skills are off like because to me it's
just not wise
it's not smart like to me there's
something and it's one thing like i
think if you both have kids that's a
different situation
um i mean i think like men i think
people can
date each other
wait hold on do you want to finish your
point yeah about um why you would do it
i wouldn't do it i don't think i have to
strength but absolutely any man who does
it yes i think i do admire him if he did
can you explain why
i think it's sacrificial the fact that
you're willing to um take all the
deficit
to make a um extended family with
someone that has it's not your kid it's
not something i would do i don't know
i wouldn't not necessarily
as someone who's done it right i would
not advise it
it was it was a lesson that
i had to learn do you get what i'm
saying like it was a lesson that i had
to learn so i wouldn't advise it yeah
however like i said and i've said this
before
men over over a certain age
if they're looking for a woman of a
certain age say around 30. yeah chances
are yeah they're gonna have a childhood
maybe a child or two you know what i
mean so that's something you've got away
up but i'm saying men who are like under
30 yeah who are like in the prime of
their life if they're looking to get
with a woman who's got a child you're an
idiot if it's not the wise i won't say
it's not the wisest
to say to say it's weak i think the
biological father not looking after
these kids that's weak but then why is
that your immediate assumption because
no i'm just i'm saying i'm saying it's
like this is showing a gynocentric
social order and especially like i know
you're involved in the church especially
in the church it's like this coddling of
women no she broke the home more than
likely she probably left no no no i
would agree in general but i'm just
saying if any man
wants to step in i think there is
something admirable when i'm doing that
i'm not advocating that like sarah said
he's had experience of it and i don't
think i'll have the strength to do that
but i'm just saying i won't listen to
that man weak
i would and i'll tell you why because
the laws are just stacked against men
so you could be on the hook for child
support of a kid that's not yours like
to me that's just stupid like i said
it's not the wisest decision as someone
who's done it you what you were and the
thing is i speak to men he's a donor
he's not offended no no of course not i
i speak to men who have done it
as well and like i said we've said it so
many times
you get 100 of the responsibility as a
father
and you do not get the authoritarian
role 100 percent either
legal rights you have no legal rights of
all the responsibility so it is not a
good thing to do in the long run it's
really not the smartest thing to do
a lesson that i had to learn for myself
but is it not down to the man to then
represent as represent himself as a
father to that child so that the father
but it will be hard for him it will be
hard if you if you unders if you
understand
mothers of children right mothers of
children have a they have a biological
connection to their child
and
they know that you don't have that
biological connection to that child
right and so whether consciously or
subconsciously they will let you know
that that's not your biological child
and it's not and it's not in it's not in
the most um
you know uh forward
way possible and like i said a lot of it
is subconscious a lot of it is little
things that i don't know at all if i was
a dad i would have been able to do that
but you know so i'm saying it's not it's
not a very good um
uh setup yeah i take a point sorry in
terms of if you're older in your 50s and
you've already got yeah yeah
and stuff like that but i suppose
when when you look at it from a cost
benefit analysis and this is how men
think if you're in your 20s just about
to your career's about to take off yeah
and you meet a single mom with two sons
run you're thinking
why would i do that no seriously yeah
yeah i've just seen it from a
superficial
run
there's no need for a man of that he
should be getting a single [ __ ]
run yeah because what she's looking for
at that age is a stepfather for her
children yeah oh i have a question do
you feel like single mother mothers can
ask for monogamy
yes
yeah i do
yeah
because you're kind of cheating them out
of the things that men value right
you're there there's clearly no purity
there
so so and you're asking a guy to
compromise his mating strategy right
which is screw as many people as
possible
and your mating strategy is to get all
the resources
it's like you're asking for a full
compromise when like it's like one-sided
go ahead i don't understand this why is
this one of men's um what did you say is
there a mating strategy no like the
things that they hold whatever
why are you
okay but hold on a second why are you
holding purity at higher regard when
you're out here beating every chick so
the the reason is because
men and women are different and that's
the thing like if a girl has had sex
with one person they're a virgin she has
an 80 chance of a happy marriage if she
slept with more than five it goes down
to 25 chance of 10 years having a happy
marriage so it's less valuable to a man
where like a dude the number one
best is if they're both virgins but if
you take that off the table like men's
marital happiness increases like from
five to eight partners where they're
more happy with the girl because we we
bond more during sex i mean that's why
we have terms like dykmatized
and can we be honest women do want a man
with sexual experience
let's just be honest that's why it's
different women do not want a man
especially when it's time to get to that
sexual place they don't want a man that
they've got to teach
they want they would prefer to be taught
by a man but a woman doesn't want a man
with no sex experience he wants to have
a man that doesn't know what he's doing
in his bedroom
for that you're going to need a man
who's got sexual experience hence the
reason why he's that he cannot be out
here banging all the chicks because he's
trying to get some experience for you
maybe i don't know i think it just
depends on the on the person yeah i'd
agree i don't wanna when i see you no
sexually with like no sexual about no
such experience personally i wouldn't
wanna date someone with no sexual
experience but then
that's just me but yeah but that means
he's got a experience
i think right now like right now so you
want a guy with a guy with sex like
that's what i'm trying to say
like why would you disagree with say the
same thing
he doesn't know how he doesn't know how
to talk to women doesn't know how to
approach women guys that do that that
doesn't have had experience yeah but he
can have experience with it doesn't mean
he has to have sexual experience she can
know how to approach a lady he may have
he may have her experience with uh leah
and rachel
yeah
what i value is a man who's got
discipline so a man who hasn't been out
in the streets like being every chick
but
doesn't he doesn't he have to know how
to speak to you as a woman and get you
to the point where you're thinking
but this is another reason why i value
family because if he comes from a family
where you know he has male figures
around him then
nine times out of ten they probably know
how to speak to the women within their
family why they've got a good unit and
that's been passed down to him so he
hasn't learned how to do these things on
the streets and i think that's a very
big issue in our society we shouldn't be
learning a lot of stuff from society we
should be learning it from the primary
point of education which is the home the
family it's like we say it takes a
village right so i feel like there's a
problem which
you know we need to get to the root of
and it's like the family unit no i i
agree with you i do think it's the
family unit but but a lot of times like
you're you're putting an old set of
values in 2022.
we can't undo birth control and although
a lot of the reason for a lack of family
is the women
it's it's us we don't want to get
married the average age of first
marriage is 31. listen i'm just going to
put it out there i'm trying to get
married
i'm trying to get married like i'm a
career-driven woman however my biggest
aspiration in life is to get married and
have a